now vice president kamala harris is
still refusing to travel to our southern
border i guess she's too busy doing
every other job that joe hands her
because he's too busy uh sleeping all
day with a sippy cup
anyway she won't go see firsthand the
crisis
and she is but she is headed to
guatemala and mexico this weekend
for her first foreign trip as vice
president probably to try and
and bribe these countries please try not
to let so many people cross the border
here with uh reaction with a big
announcement as well the host of a brand
new show here on the fox news channel
unfiltered with dan bongino
it premieres saturday at 10 p.m
right here on fox by the way what were
we going to call it
filter dan bongino uh you know
you don't know any other speed you've
got one speed
and it usually gets a little faster
though sometimes if you're up against
geraldo then it becomes
speed on steroids but go ahead welcome
aboard congratulations
yeah yeah that's a good way to sum it up
thank you my friend
i'm going to take a little tip from you
in the show
for those who don't know sean he can
rarely stick to the teleprompter ever he
just kind of does his own
thing so i told him go light on the copy
i just want to do the damp on geno thing
which again is totally unfiltered you're
right filtering yourself
filtered oh yeah nobody would watch damn
pongino filtered so it's got to be
unfiltered
i don't think there is a dead body i
don't think so we i
mean oh by the way everywhere i go
dan and geraldo hate each other i said
they don't really hate each other they
just get a little hot under the collar
that's all
well congratulations you know that
happens on tv thank you
oh i wouldn't know anything about that
um all right so let me ask you this
um you heard sarah's report you see
the highest numbers of illegal
immigration coming into this country in
over 20 years
we see the perilous journey kids are
taking a loan
we know that it is open market for the
drug traffickers human traffickers
this is as bad as it gets dan and it's
all caused
by open borders joe what do we do
yeah a couple a couple of takeaways on
this on the kamala harris front
knowing how she'll leverage any
political opportunity for a photo
op or a sound bite you think she's
avoiding the border by accident
she's avoiding the border because she
knows it's an apocalyptic disaster
if she thought this was a success story
sean she'd be down there tomorrow with
the washington post
with a photo op and vogue or something
like that i mean
give me a break she of course she
understands this is a disaster now
the second point on this is what's
really frustrating about this listening
to sarah's report
and you know on a very serious note
listening this morning to fox and
friends you know i consume content on
the station too i don't just work here
and i heard this story this morning
there was a woman being raped on the
border she got
shot border patrol had a rescuer this is
total anarchy down there
the democrats talk about this like there
isn't an alternative sean
like there isn't an actual legal process
for people to go to like oh
stay in mexico kids people build the
walls it's insane yeah
right exactly doing it the legal way i
mean it makes sense
yeah uh congratulations we're proud of
you
it's um well deserved and look forward
to seeing your
first show uh sunday night 10 p.m
filtered dan bongino is never
going to be in existence that's why it's
unfiltered
uh dan congratulations thank you when we
come back hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else